you're right i don't feel special i
think
also i have a
can i ask you a question i hate to ask
this but um
and i know i've been doing comedy for so
long bill
and i need
advice is that
because i can never tell if you're being
so i'm being [ __ ] dead serious right
now okay i need help
i need help
what is your problem
um for the last couple years maybe five
years
on stage
i'll do like one i'll squeeze in one new
joke
this and that but like my shit's not
growing and i'm not having fun with it
and i'm afraid to bomb oh you got to get
past that yeah i'm afraid to bomb yeah
you just gotta and i'm in that locked-in
thing so it's like when i'm at a club
and it's packed and i'm following all
these guys i have an agenda like i'm
gonna do this new joke this joke but
once i'm up there
i go i gotta kill because there's a
crowd here how do i get through with it
yeah i need help what would feel better
after that
when you go home
and you lay your little asian head on
your pillow
that was made by white sweatshop work
yeah
well made by mike lindell what's gonna
make you feel better
uh uh
knowing that you tried and you're bombed
on knowing that you're chickened out
what's gonna make you feel worse i
should say knowing that you chickened
out it's so funny that you say that
because um every time i'm in the car
driving home
if you could see if you had a camera
outside my
car window and you were filming it on a
wide shot this is what you'd see
you know i mean i'm like yelling at
myself now why do you think i know that
because you've seen me no
i went through the same thing oh you did
yeah when i used to wanted to do the uh
sunday night at the boston i'd always
would chicken out uh in new york it was
it was talent in uh will silvent's show
the all-black show i knew i could do
well on it and i kept chickening out
like you know three weeks in a row then
i'd be laying in in my railroad
apartment in my little skinny bed going
i hate myself i hate myself i hate
myself and then finally one night i was
like okay what's gonna feel worse
going in and doing this and bombing
or [ __ ] chickening out and laying and
i just knew that just you know
not doing it so i went in and i actually
ended up having a great set
and then it changed from that moment or
was it something that you said
my whole life has been baby steps baby
steps baby steps baby steps trying to
get over something that i think is a
mountain and it's like stepping up on a
curb by the time you do it you're like
oh is that all it was ah that's what it
is so you just have to go out there pick
a night go up to the belly room
and just pick a night and be like i'm
just gonna [ __ ]
do these three things that i don't give
a [ __ ] how they go i'm gonna give them
my all i'm gonna have a good time all
you got to do is just if you're bombing
you just make fun of yourself yeah
and it was so funny that you say this
because you would think that i would
know this after 30 years here i mean no
but there's all there's
there's no rhyme or reason to it you
know who's great at jim norton jim
norton recently he's been posting a
bunch of like you know more content is
[ __ ] hilarious yeah i love him but
he'll occasionally he'll post a joke
that doesn't do well
and it ends up like him commenting on it
not doing well ends up killing harder
than you know
all right
yeah yeah he'll be like god damn it i
had such high hopes for that everybody
just it just releases the tension yeah i
think in the beginning you're going back
to when you first were a comedian you
didn't know how to release the tension
so it just became like awful awful awful
you know that's why i was better to bomb
in front of a black crowd because i felt
like their vibe is we're having fun
either with you or without you
so if you start bombing they just start
laughing and heckling so there's the
show continues
the show's either gonna be your act the
jokes you're telling them or it's gonna
be them just now toying with you
so yeah anyway i would just yeah just do
that and i think the more comics that
you tell that you're you're scared to do
that the more we'll support you to get
out there and go do it and then you'll
go do it you see that see that's why i
never
have i ever asked that question before
[Music]
no no no because
it's so hard to ask
so hard to ask a guy that you you know
that you work with and that you admire
and then go how do i do this or how do i
get back you know and i think that um
i'm a bald orange man
what does that mean it just means who
the [ __ ] am i what is that look at me